When you open the newspaper or turn on the nightly news or scroll the internet, is what you are reading and seeing true? How do you know? What is fake news and why does it seem to be everywhere? Americans are worried about fake news. A 2019 poll by the Pew Research Center found that half of Americans said that made up news is a very big problem. Sixty-eight percent said it affects our confidence in government institutions and 54 percent said it is having a major impact. on our confidence in each other. But what does the research say? Why do people believe fake news?
当你翻开报纸、打开晚间新闻或浏览互联网时，你所阅读和看到的是真的吗？你怎么知道？什么是假新闻？为什么它似乎无处不在？美国人对假新闻感到担忧。皮尤研究中心 2019 年的一项民意调查发现，半数美国人认为虚假新闻是一个非常严重的问题。百分之六十八的人表示，这影响了我们对政府机构的信心；百分之五十四的人表示，它对我们彼此之间的信心产生了重大影响。但研究是怎么说的？为什么人们会相信假新闻？
How easily does misinformation spread? And once a person believes a lie, is it possible to convince them of the truth? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Dolores Albarasin,
虚假信息的传播有多容易？一旦有人相信了谎言，还有可能让他们相信真相吗？欢迎收看《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是多洛雷斯·阿尔巴拉辛博士，
a professor of psychology and business at the University of Illinois Urbana-Champaign. She studies attitudes, persuasion, and behavior, and has looked at how people respond to misinformation in areas including politics, vaccines, and other health behaviors. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Albarsim. Thank you, Kim. Thanks for having me. You published a study that looked at psychologists' research on debunking, that is, changing people's minds once they've been presented with misinformation.
她是伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-尚佩恩分校的心理学和商业教授。她研究态度、说服和行为，并探讨了人们如何对政治、疫苗和其他健康行为等领域的错误信息做出反应。欢迎来到心理学讲堂，阿尔巴拉西姆博士。谢谢你，金。谢谢邀请我。你发表了一项研究，探讨了心理学家对辟谣的研究，也就是说，在向人们提供错误信息后改变他们的想法。
Once someone believes a piece of misinformation, is it possible to correct that belief? What did you find? Yes, within that study, which was published in psychological science in 2017, and this was a meta-analysis of the impact of misinformation presented in the news or similar types of print. So a lot of this is, of course, experimental work, and that was what we were after. So the meta-analysis, which is a collection of all the evidence on a problem in a quantitative way, involves collecting all the research that have been done on misinformation that's presented to somebody that is later corrected. So what is the impact of first the misinformation and second the correction itself?
一旦有人相信了某条错误信息，是否有可能纠正这种信念？你们发现了什么？是的，在那项研究中，该研究于 2017 年发表在《心理科学》杂志上，这是对新闻或类似印刷品中出现的错误信息的元分析。因此，其中很大一部分当然是实验工作，这也是我们所追求的。因此，元分析是以定量方式收集有关某个问题的所有证据的过程，涉及收集针对某人提出并随后得到纠正的错误信息所做的所有研究。那么，首先是错误信息，其次是纠正本身，它们的影响是什么？
So we gathered all the experiments, the information was new, the misinformation was new to participants on new issues, and then we estimated the odds that if you present misinformation, people will actually believe it. And the results show that the odds are actually quite high, 266 to 1. So that means that 99.6% of your attempt, to misinform will actually be successful.
因此，我们收集了所有实验，信息是新的，错误信息对参与者来说是关于新问题的新信息，然后我们估计了如果你提供错误信息，人们实际上会相信它的几率。结果显示，这个几率其实相当高，达到 266 比 1。这意味着你传递虚假信息有 99.6% 的成功率。
So this is by far the strongest effects I've ever estimated in my career. So is it easy to misinform? Yeah, it's extremely easy. If you present misinformation, it will take a whole of your mind. It will stick. Can we actually correct that misinformation that we introduced? Yes. But it's not as easy as when we introduce the misinformation.
因此，这是我职业生涯中估计过的迄今为止最强烈的效果。那么，传播虚假信息很容易吗？是的，极其容易。如果你提供虚假信息，它就会占据你的大脑。它会挥之不去。我们真的能纠正我们引入的错误信息吗？是的。但这不像我们引入错误信息时那么容易。
the first time, the odds of correcting properly are actually 6 to 1. That means that 86% of the time, the correction will succeed. But remember that the success rate of the misinformation is pretty close to 100% that leaves you with a gap. What are some of the strategies for correcting misinformation, and are there some that work better than others? There are a number of strategies, and these actually lead to better results overall. First, you should briefly and clearly describe the misinformation you're correcting. So you're both alluding to the initial piece that was fake, and whatever is that you want to introduce is as the true information that you would like people to remember.
第一次时，正确纠正的几率其实是 6 比 1。这意味着 86% 的情况下，纠正会成功。但请记住，错误信息的成功率非常接近 100%，这就给你留下了一个差距。纠正错误信息的一些策略是什么？有没有一些比其他策略更有效？有多种策略，这些实际上能带来更好的总体结果。首先，你应该简短而清晰地描述你正在纠正的错误信息。因此，你既提到了最初的假消息，也提到了你想要作为人们应该记住的真实信息引入的内容。
then you present the correction briefly but clearly even sometimes through graphics that could be quite effective. Explain why the initial misinformation was wrong. This is key. You need to really provide complete explanations for why the new information is right and what was a problem with the initial take. So for that, what you really want is to ensure a good match between the misinformation people received and your correction. The correction has to map to the misinformation. So imagine a contemporary case like the case of emails that were supposedly found on a computer that was left for repair. So if you take this claim and you're trying to counter it, and then you say, well, there weren't any emails or that was false. Simply saying that was false, it's not going to cut it.
然后简短而清晰地展示纠正措施，有时甚至通过图表，这可能相当有效。解释最初的错误信息为什么是错的。这是关键。你需要真正提供完整的解释，说明为什么新信息是正确的，以及最初的看法有什么问题。为此，你真正想要确保的是人们收到的错误信息与你的纠正之间有很好的匹配。纠正必须与错误信息相对应。想象一个当代案例，比如据称在送修的电脑上找到的电子邮件案例。因此，如果你接受这一说法并试图反驳它，然后你说，嗯，没有任何电子邮件，或者那是假的。仅仅说那是假的，是行不通的。
You need to explain how did the computer end up and where and were there emails and were there other types of emails in there? What exactly was the content and what happened? So you don't really touch on all the points and simply say, no, that wasn't really. true, it's unfounded, you're not going to successfully transform what people hand-represented to begin, and that's pretty important. So the other point is you need to be using trustworthy sources. This could sometimes be expert sources, but actually trusting the sources is even more important than expertise.
你需要解释电脑是如何下落不明的，在哪里，是否有电子邮件，里面是否有其他类型的电子邮件？具体内容是什么？发生了什么？所以你并没有真正触及所有点，只是简单地说，不，那不是真的，那是毫无根据的，你将无法成功地改变人们最初持有的观念，这非常重要。所以另一点是，你需要使用值得信赖的信息源。有时这可能是专家来源，但实际上相信信息源比专业知识更重要。
So are you having Fauci telling you what you should be hearing about the coronavirus and is he a trustworthy source for you? In addition, you need to encourage the audience to counterargue and be active with the information. The more people produce their own counterarguments, both ahead of time and at the point in which you introduce the correction, the better your results will be. So the fact that people can be critical and think deeply about the information is
那么，你是在让福奇告诉你关于冠状病毒的事吗？他是一个值得信赖的信息源吗？此外，你需要鼓励受众进行反驳并积极对待信息。人们产生自己的反驳越多，无论是在事先还是在你引入纠正的时候，你的结果就会越好。因此，人们能够批判性地思考信息是
extremely important. There are several very important recommendations and guidelines. For instance, the International Federation of Library Associations has a set of published guidelines that actually appear as a diagram. And they tell you you should first consider the source, what's the mission, right? What's the possible bias here? You need to really go beyond the headline because the headline can be misleading. Check the authors, do they exist?
极其重要的。有几个非常重要的建议和指导方针。例如，国际图书馆协会联合会有一套发布的指南，实际上以图表的形式出现。他们告诉你，首先应该考虑信源，使命是什么？这里的潜在偏见是什么？你需要超越头条新闻，因为头条新闻可能会产生误导。检查作者，他们存在吗？
Are they credible? So this is all regular practices that you can use to check on the information as it comes in. And so there is a recent document produced by 22 authors led by Steve Lewandowski, and I was part of this. And it's, I think, a very useful step towards providing guidelines for journalists and professionals to actually correct for misinformation. So they summarize all these aspects of how the correction can be done. So that's great for, as you say, journalists, other professionals, but you're a lot of, average person is going to be more likely to maybe look at something like snopes.com to figure out whether something is true or not. Isn't that the case? Yes, I think that's true in terms of
他们可信吗？因此，这些都是你可以用来检查涌入的信息的常规做法。因此，由史蒂夫·莱万多夫斯基领导的 22 位作者最近发布了一份文件，我是其中的一部分。我认为，这是朝着为记者和专业人士提供纠正错误信息的指南迈出的非常有用的一步。因此，他们总结了如何进行纠正的所有这些方面。正如你所说，这对记者和其他专业人士来说很好，但你很多的普通人更有可能去看诸如 snopes.com 之类的网站来弄清楚某事是否属实。难道不是这样吗？是的，我认为这在
your own fact checking of information. But in terms of making sure that whatever corrections are issued, we have the best possible instances of those. I think the document could be important in that sense. Let's talk a little bit about how, a little more about how this is playing out in the real world. There was an article in the Washington Post recently about the Biden campaign so-called Malarkey Factory, which is their nickname for the campaign's efforts to counter disinformation online. One thing that I thought was interesting is that the staffers said in the article that a critical part of their job has been figuring out which fake stories to counter and which to ignore. Yes, it's a really interesting article and problem, and they seem to be using various efforts to combat this information in this case.
你自己的事实核查方面是正确的。但就确保发布的任何更正都是最好的情况而言。我认为这份文件在这方面可能很重要。让我们多谈谈这在现实世界中是如何发挥作用的。最近《华盛顿邮报》上有一篇文章关于拜登竞选团队所谓的“胡说八道工厂”，这是他们对竞选团队在网上打击虚假信息努力的绰号。我 认为有趣的一点是，文章中的工作人员表示，他们工作的一个关键部分一直是弄清楚该反击哪些假故事以及该忽略哪些。是的，这是一个非常有趣的文章和问题，在这种情况下，他们似乎正在利用各种努力来打击这一信息。
They seem to be gauging primarily the resonance of a given attack for persuadable voters, right? And I think this is a really good strategy in the sense that you're not going to really change the, ston't conservatives in this case who are pro-Trump no matter what and this is the same type of problem that we have in the health domain
他们似乎主要在衡量特定攻击对可被说服的选民的共鸣，对吧？我认为这是一个非常好的策略，因为在这个案例中，你不会真正改变坚定的保守派，他们无论如何都亲特朗普，我们在健康领域也有同样类型的问题
and especially areas that are to polarize like that seems right you're not going to introduce persuasive messages on social media to try to change the parents who are leading the anti-vax movement right? You have absolutely no chance of producing changes. Couldn't they change? Yes, they could change maybe if they married a liberal or really alter their lives, which would take years, and that could produce a change.
特别是像这样极端两极分化的领域，这似乎是正确的，你不会在社交媒体上发布说服信息来试图改变领导反疫苗运动的父母，对吧？你产生改变的绝对机会为零。难道他们不能改变吗？是的，如果他们与一个自由派结婚或者真正改变他们的生活，他们可能会改变，但这需要数年时间，并且这可能会产生改变。
But you're not going to change them through an actual message or correction, but you have a really good chance when people who are on the fence, who aren't certain who might have seen something, but they are not positive of what it was or where it came from, and therefore they are persuadable in that sense. Who are trusted sources today, though? I mean, that seems to be a big problem because at one time you might be able to say, well, the news media, New York Times, the Washington Post, those are trusted sources. But now we have all kinds of, policymakers, politicians saying they're fake news. Who do you turn to? And you mentioned Dr. Anthony Fauci as somebody who might be trusted. Is it individuals at this point? Or are there institutions that are
但你不会通过实际的信息或纠正来改变他们，但是当人们处于摇摆不定、不确定可能看过什么但又不确定它是什么或来自哪里的人时，你有很好的机会，因此从这个意义上说他们是可以被说服的。不过，今天谁是值得信赖的信息源？我的意思是，这似乎是一个大问题，因为曾经你可能会说，嗯，新闻媒体，《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》，那些是值得信赖的信息源。但现在我们有各种各样的政策制定者、政治家说他们是假新闻。你向谁求助？你提到了安东尼·福奇博士是一个可能被信任的人。目前是个人吗？还是有机构
trustworthy sources? Yes, I think that's a really crucial problem and I wish I had answers for you. Unfortunately, you know, the level of cynicism and the population has only gone up over the years. And in the last four years, especially trust in the media has decreased tremendously as a result of all we've seen. So in general, trusted sources could involve reputable media. but if we call the reputable media now fake news factories or whatever we used to denigrate those trusted sources, then they are no longer possible correction sources for everybody at least. But there's still some people who will believe them. Yes, of course, yes.
是值得信赖的信息源？是的，我认为这是一个非常关键的问题，我希望我有答案给你。不幸的是，你知道，民众的 cynicism（愤世嫉俗）水平这些年来只增不减。在过去的四年里，特别是由于我们所看到的一切，对媒体的信任大大下降。因此，总的来说，值得信赖的信息源可能包括信誉良好的媒体。但如果我们现在把信誉良好的媒体称为假新闻工厂或任何我们用来诋毁这些值得信赖的信息源的词，那么它们就不再是适合所有人的潜在纠正信息源了。但仍然有一些人会相信它们。是的，当然，是的。
But you're not reaching necessarily everybody in the same way. way and some people are increasingly more isolated from any formal source of information, which then allows all these other misinformation and disinformation out there to filter itself and potentially have an impact because there is a vacuum of regularly infused correct information. So in respect to the Biden campaign, I think what's key in addition to is this an audience that's persuadable, is this misinformation actionable? Or what are the behavioral implications of believing that, let's say, Biden is a socialist? Well, for some groups, that's quite important, right? So if you take Cuban Americans or Venezuelans and they see that possibility and they immediately imagine we're going to have some type of communists redeem coming in, that could be quite persuasive and that will definitely bias and shape how they vote.
但你并不一定以同样的方式接触到每一个人，而且有些人越来越孤立于任何正式的信息来源之外，这反过来又让所有其他错误信息和虚假信息在外面过滤自己并可能产生影响，因为存在定期注入的正确信息的真空。因此，关于拜登竞选团队，我认为除了这是否是一个可以被说服的受众之外的关键是，这种错误信息是否具有可操作性？或者相信假设拜登是社会主义者有什么行为影响？嗯，对一些群体来说，这相当重要，对吧？因此，如果你带上古巴裔美国人或委内瑞拉人，他们看到了这种可能性，并立即想象我们将迎来某种共产主义救赎，这可能会非常具有说服力，并且绝对会偏见和塑造他们的投票方式。
In addition, there is actionable misinformation that's even more problematic, which is. is the type that was used in the 2016 campaign that was essentially suppressing the vote, right? So if you see an ad that tells you, click here to vote online, well, that is extremely problematic, much more than commenting on Biden falling asleep in a meeting, right? So I would say, yes, the potential to persuade,
此外，还有更具问题的可操作的错误信息，即2016年竞选活动中使用的那种本质上是压制投票的类型，对吧？因此，如果你看到一个广告告诉你，点击这里在线投票，嗯，这极其成问题，远比评论拜登在会议上打瞌睡要严重得多，对吧？所以我会说，是的，说服的潜力，
but also the actionableity of the misinformation on going after whatever is clearly linked to behavior, which is not all of it. Something that interests me in particular is conspiracy theories. And I would just wonder why people believe them, even the most outlandish. And just to give one example, I mean, the 2016 Pizza Gate conspiracy theory, for example, that alleged members of the Democratic Party were running a pedophilia ring in the basement of a pizza parlor in Washington, D.C. Why is it that some people can believe something that is so outlandish just on its face?
但也包括针对任何与行为明确相关的错误信息的行动性，这并非全部。让我特别感兴趣的是阴谋论。我只是想知道为什么人们相信它们，甚至是那些最离奇的。仅举一个例子，我的意思是，2016 年的“披萨门”阴谋论，例如，声称民主党成员在华盛顿特区一家披萨店的地下室经营恋童癖团伙。为什么有些人仅仅凭表面现象就能相信如此离奇的事情？
Is there something that goes on in our brains? Yes, I've been fascinated by this, and I began to study that, like around 2013, and people were saying, why are you studying this? It's really not an issue. Nobody believes in this. But, of course, they want to say the same thing nowadays, right? We are seeing more and more far-fetch ideas that you couldn't imagine people would believe and they look completely science fiction-like in a lot of cases, right? But yes, people do.
我们的脑子里发生了什么吗？是的，我对此着迷，我大约在 2013 年开始研究这个，当时人们说，你为什么在研究这个？这根本不是个问题。没有人相信这个。但是，当然，他们现在想说同样的事情，对吧？我们看到越来越多你无法想象人们会相信的荒谬想法，在许多情况下它们看起来完全像科幻小说，对吧？但是的，人们确实相信。
It's a quarter of the population believes that the coronavirus is potentially a bioweapon, that it's a quarter of the population. believes that the coronavirus is potentially a bioweapon that escaped, or at least they did believe those kinds of things in the beginning of the pandemic. So the question of why, well, it's quite interesting, and it's led to a lot of research. And if you look at what people have said about the origins of this, Well, first of all, it can give you a pretty tight scheme to sort of tie all of your beliefs too. It explains a lot of the stress of our lives and our failures, right?
有四分之一的人认为冠状病毒可能是生物武器，四分之一的人认为冠状病毒可能是逃逸的生物武器，或者至少他们在疫情初期是这样认为的。所以为什么的问题，嗯，这非常有趣，并引发了大量的研究。如果你看看人们对它的起源是怎么说的，嗯，首先，它可以为你提供一个非常紧密的方案来将你所有的信念联系起来。它解释了我们生活中的许多压力和失败，对吧？
So there is one take that essentially that conspiracy beliefs take on because people are frustrated and they have been socially excluded. And now they have a great reason, right? not because of my own failures, rather there is people, lizards conspiracy out there. And of course, that power is keeping me in my current situation. However, when you look at all the possible personality variables that might explain these beliefs, they account for very little. So they don't really contribute that much. And if it were only personality, then you would imagine that we would all come up with our own unique theories, right?
因此，有一种观点认为，阴谋论之所以兴起，是因为人们感到沮丧并且被社会排斥。现在他们有了一个很好的理由，对吧？不是因为我自己的失败，而是外面有人，蜥蜴阴谋。当然，那种力量让我保持在我目前的处境中。然而，当你查看所有可能解释这些信念的人格变量时，它们只占很小一部分。所以它们并没有做出那么大的贡献。如果仅仅是人格，那么你可以想象我们都会想出自己独特的理论，对吧？
For you, it would be about your neighbors, for somebody else, they would be their boss. They would look much more like pathological cases of paranoia. However, these beliefs are socially shared. So when we look at that, we really need to wonder where are the students? stories coming from, who is feeding the stories to the public. And in our own work, the origin or at least the correlates of these beliefs are exposure to the conservative media in the U.S. You also do research on misinformation around vaccines and other health behaviors.
对你来说，可能是你的邻居，对别人来说，可能是他们的老板。它们看起来更像是偏执狂的病态病例。然而，这些信念是在社会上共享的。所以当我们看到这一点时，我们真的需要想一想，这些故事是从哪里来的？是谁在向公众灌输这些故事？在我们自己的工作中，这些信念的起源或至少是相关因素是接触了美国的保守派媒体。你还对围绕疫苗和其他健康行为的错误信息进行研究。
And in one recent study, you looked at how the amount of misinformation in people's social media environments affect whether they get the flu vaccine. Can you talk a little bit about what you found? Yes. So in that study, there is, of course, information and we suspected that the anti-vax movement and vaccination hesitancy could be links to exposure to misinformation on social media. We wanted the first to actually raise that question. That question has. it's been around for a long time. And the previous work was typically work looking to see if people who have vaccine hesitancy are likely to, let's say, hang out in anti-vax groups on Facebook.
在最近的一项研究中，你探讨了人们社交媒体环境中的错误信息量如何影响他们是否接种流感疫苗。你能多谈谈你发现了什么吗？是的。因此，在那项研究中，当然有信息，我们怀疑反疫苗运动和疫苗犹豫可能与接触社交媒体上的错误信息有关。我们想要成为第一个真正提出这个问题的人。这个问题已经
And yes, of course, that is the case. But then you don't know, is in that they all hang together because they have these beliefs or are they actually persuaded because they are in the groups. So what we wanted to do was to come up with research that could answer that question of the temporal order better. So we had two types of data. On the one hand, we collected tweets primarily on vaccine hesitancy themes. That would involve, for instance, a big pharma conspiracy and the fact that kids are damaged for the the profit of the pharmaceutical industry.
存在很长时间了。以前的工作通常是观察对疫苗犹豫不决的人是否更有可能，比如说，在 Facebook 上的反疫苗群组中闲逛。是的，当然，事实确实如此。但随后你并不知道，是因为他们都有这些信念所以才聚在一起，还是因为他们在群组里而真正被说服了。所以我们想要做的是提出一项能够更好地回答时间顺序那个问题的研究。所以我们有两种类型的数据。一方面，我们收集了主要关于疫苗犹豫主题的推特。这可能涉及，例如，大型制药公司阴谋以及儿童为了制药行业的利润而受到损害的事实。
So we had those tweets and we delocated in the tweets to the U.S. county in which they were initially produced. In addition, we had a survey of 3,000 Americans who participated over time. So we had a full year of data on vaccine attitudes and vaccination behavior. So this was done when the flu shot because that's something we should all be getting all adults. And it was a good case and should actually observe influences on actual behavior. And what we found was that in general, if you live in a county that has that kind of misinformation circulating around on Twitter, later on, you're more likely to be.
所以我们有了这些推特，并将推特定位到它们最初产生的美国县。此外，我们对随着时间推移参与的 3,000 名美国人进行了调查。因此，我们有了一整年的疫苗态度和疫苗接种行为数据。所以这是在流感疫苗接种时进行的，因为那是我们所有成年人都应该接种的。这是一个很好的案例，并且应该能够实际观察对实际行为的影响。我们发现，总的来说，如果你生活在一个在推特上流传这种错误信息的县，稍后你更有可能
disapprove of vaccines and also less likely to get a flu shot. However, if you also have discussions with friends, your physician, and it's real life network, then that effect disappears, which is important in the sense that, you know, and gives you a possible key to disarm the effects of being exposed to negative information, of that type. Which speaks again to relying on trusted sources, right?
不赞成疫苗，也不太可能接种流感疫苗。然而，如果你还与朋友、你的医生和现实生活网络进行讨论，那么这种效应就会消失，这在某种程度上很重要，并为你提供了消除接触这种类型的负面信息的影响的可能关键。这再次说明了依赖值得信赖的信息源，对吧？
Right. And social consensus and social proof of some sort. So what happens in situations where people believe false information, not because it's fake news, but because information changes. For example, at the beginning of the COVID pandemic, reputable authorities advise the general public that they didn't need to wear masks, but that obviously changed. So how can health officials and public officials deal with situations like this? Yes, I think you're really pointing to a problem that we're not always emphasizing. We're more concerned with correct information, but in a fairly unstable situation that is a pandemic. And for a new disease, in this case, this situation of.
对。以及某种形式的社会共识和社会证明。那么，当人们相信虚假信息时，会发生什么情况？不是因为它是假新闻，而是因为信息发生了变化。例如，在新冠疫情初期，权威机构建议普通大众不需要戴口罩，但这显然发生了变化。那么，卫生官员和公共官员如何处理这样的情况呢？是的，我认为你确实指出一个我们并不总是强调的问题。我们更关心正确的信息，但在一个相当不稳定且是疫情的情况下。对于一种新疾病，在这种情况下，
having to correct your own information, which was true at that time, is essentially, you know, in monthly occurrence, right, in different ways. So the psychological processes are the same. So whether you're correcting false or true information at the time, you know, they're both false right now. So you're going to need to go to the same trouble of experience. explaining why we didn't believe we needed masks and now we do what has changed and what was actually correct in the time. So you need to try to control the damage and not allow for your change in perspective to essentially cast doubt over the entire understanding of the COVID-19 pandemic.
不得不纠正你自己的信息（当时这是真的），本质上你知道，每个月都会发生，对吧，以不同的方式。所以心理过程是一样的。因此，无论你当时是在纠正错误信息还是真实信息，你知道，它们现在都是错的。所以你需要经历同样的麻烦，解释为什么我们认为不需要口罩而现在需要了，什么变了，以及当时什么是真正正确的。所以你需要尝试控制损害，不要让你的观点转变本质上对整个新冠肺炎疫情的理解产生怀疑。
So the corrections need to repeat the misinformation, whatever. you believed earlier, in the same way with the same complete explanations, but by trustworthy sources that you need in the case of correcting for misinformation. So this is, of course, also something that we're seeing in the vaccine trials, right? And probably what you need to do is anticipate that this is a new field. we don't know enough and we're likely to change the point of view as we go. So with that in mind, you can proactively control the potential damage of these changes. So there will be different ways, but one might be to really elaborate on, well, at this point, this is what we believe,
因此，纠正措施需要重复错误信息，无论你之前相信什么，以相同的方式进行完整的解释，但由你在纠正错误信息时需要的那种值得信赖的信息源来完成。因此，这当然也是我们在疫苗试验中看到的情况，对吧？可能你需要做的是预测这是一个新领域，我们了解得还不够，我们可能会随着进展改变观点。因此，考虑到这一点，你可以主动控制这些变化的潜在损害。所以会有不同的方式，但其中一种可能是真正阐述，嗯，在这一点上，这就是我们所相信的，
or at this point there is a halt in the clinical trial, but this is, something that happens regularly and it doesn't mean that if three months from now the vaccine appears and it's demonstrated to be efficacious, that doesn't mean that, you know, this event is not invalidating that other conclusion that we might reach down the line. So I think that's the critical piece here to be anticipating the future when you are communicating. communicating information in areas as consequential as public health and also that are in flux. One study that came out this year in the journal Science found that fake news itself was actually not as prevalent as we might think. The researchers concluded that actual fake news comprised only 0.15% of the average Americans news diet.
或者在这一点上临床试验暂停了，但这是经常发生的事情，这并不意味着如果从现在起三个月后疫苗出现并被证明是有效的，这并不意味着，你知道，这个事件没有使我们以后可能得出的另一个结论无效。因此，我认为这是这里的关键部分，即在公共卫生等后果重大且处于动荡中的领域交流信息时预测未来。今年在《科学》杂志上发表的一项研究发现，假新闻本身其实并没有我们想象的那么普遍。研究人员得出结论，实际的假新闻仅占普通美国人新闻消费的 0.15%。
I'm so curious to get your thoughts on this. I mean, how big a problem is fake news? And is it still a problem if the actual percentage of all the fake news within the news universe is really quite low? I thought it was a great piece that it really challenged that idea that we're drowning in fake news. And I would tend to agree because their conclusion is that, yes, I mean, people are clearly misinformed, right? even if we're only finding that 0.15% of the news are fake, well, the public is still dramatically misinformed in a lot of areas, right? If you look at political knowledge, health knowledge, and so on.
我很想听听你对这件事的看法。我的意思是，假新闻是一个多大的问题？如果新闻宇宙中所有假新闻的实际比例真的很低，它仍然是一个问题吗？我认为这是一篇很棒的文章，它真正挑战了我们被假新闻淹没的观点。我倾向于同意，因为他们的结论是，是的，我的意思是，人们显然被错误地告知了，对吧？即使我们只发现 0.15% 的新闻是假的，嗯，公众在许多领域仍然被严重错误地告知，对吧？如果你看看政治知识、健康知识等等。
So when they conclude is that the sources of misinformation are probably not the fake news posts online, but rather the media, other people, you know, the regular sources with which we interact. And I couldn't agree more with this. So first you have a problem of lack of information and exposure to bias media. That's a serious and more prevalent problem. This is confirmed by, you know, much research,
因此，当他们得出结论时，错误信息的来源可能不是网上的假新闻帖子，而是媒体、其他人，你知道，我们与之互动的常规来源。我对此非常赞同。首先，你面临着缺乏信息和接触有偏见的媒体的问题。这是一个严重且更普遍的问题。这得到了许多研究的证实，
including our own. So if you measure associations between, let's say, conspiracy beliefs in the area of COVID-19 and social media or regular media, conservative, liberal mainstream, exposure to social media or social media usage is uncorrelated with those beliefs, but exposure to Fox News is. So I agree in that sense that both the amount, but also the impact, as we know it, is much higher for media than fake news per se. So that's part. But of course, 0.15% could still have an impact in some cases. And when it comes to something like an election, we're talking about a very, very, very, small margins. So even the point 15, and especially certain types of point 15, like the case of
包括我们自己的研究。因此，如果你衡量新冠肺炎领域的阴谋信念与社交媒体或常规媒体（保守派、自由派主流）之间的关联，接触社交媒体或社交媒体的使用与这些信念不相关，但接触福克斯新闻是相关的。所以在某种程度上我同意这一点，无论是数量，还是我们所知道的影响，媒体都远高于假新闻本身。所以这是一部分。但是，当然，0.15% 在某些情况下仍然会产生影响。当涉及到像选举这样的事情时，我们在谈论非常非常非常小的差距。所以即使是 0.15%，尤其是某些类型的 0.15%，比如
click to vote online, that could be quite damaging. And I think it makes sense to prepare for that, even if the threat is not as prevalent in terms of its size. Do you have advice for a lay person? Most of the people who listen to this podcast, They're not psychologists or journalists. How should they determine whether what they're reading and seeing out there in the world right now is true? Yes, I think there are two aspects and probably paying attention to what you're reading and slowing down is one. But generally, it all comes down to certain behavioral skills. for any other behavior.
点击在线投票的情况，那可能会相当具有破坏性。我认为为之做准备是有意义的，即使威胁在规模上没有那么普遍。你对普通人有什么建议？听这个播客的大多数人，他们不是心理学家或记者。他们应该如何判断他们在当今世界上阅读和看到的东西是否真实？是的，我认为有两个方面，可能注意你正在阅读的内容并放慢速度是一个方面。但总的来说，这一切都归结为某些行为技能，
So if you think of changing your diet, right, what do we do to teach people to change what they eat? Well, you tell them how to shop and what choices to make and so on. And I tell them don't shop on the 7-Eleven down the street or don't shop when you're hungry. So for media diets, we have the same exact problem. So the first thing to communicate and to train people in is that Facebook and YouTube are the equivalent of McDonald's body indicates of your media diet. So you should not be using either of those or social media as the main sources of news. If you see something on Twitter, go read it on the New York Times page because that's an actual reputable source of news.
对于任何其他行为而言。因此，如果你考虑改变饮食，对吧？我们做什麽来教人们改变他们吃的东西？嗯，你告诉他们如何购物，做出什麽选择等等。我告诉他们不要在街角的 7-Eleven 购物，或者不要在饿的时候购物。因此，对于媒体饮食，我们有完全相同的问题。所以要交流和训练人们的第一件事是，Facebook 和 YouTube 相当於你的媒体饮食中的麦当劳。因此，你不应该将这两者或社交媒体用作主要的新闻来源。如果你在 Twitter 上看到什麽，去《纽约时报》网页上阅读，因为那是真正信誉良好的新闻来源。
information on actual events. So that would be probably the number one aspect, where to consume the news and then the strategies of check parallel sources, don't stay with just one and slow down. But I think the number one would be don't read news on Facebook. Go to a newspaper. That's excellent advice. I appreciate you're giving it to our listeners, and I want to thank Thank you for joining us today. It's been a pleasure talking with you. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org
关於实际事件的信息。所以这可能是第一大方面，在哪里消费新闻，然後是检查平行来源的策略，不要只停留在一个并放慢速度。但我认为第一大是不要在 Facebook 上看新闻。去报纸。这是极好的建议。我很感激你把它送给我们的听众，我想感谢你今天加入我们。与你交谈非常愉快。谢谢。你可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 上找到《心理学说话》以前的节目
or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在你获取播客的任何地方。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，at APA.org。Speaking of Psychology 由李·温纳曼 (Lee Weinerman) 制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪安 (Chris Condyenne)。感谢收听美国心理学协会节目。我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。